what's your typical day like if let's
say you're not on set like what time do
you usually get up and what what do you
do monday wednesday friday i get up at
six in the morning and I go and I work
out one of my best friend's a trainer
and try to stay in really good shape and
I do that I read scripts i go to jujitsu
i go to kickboxing I've acting class at
night and then I do it all over again
and its variations on that you know my
life is very much martial arts I acting
acting class and auditions I guess and
you know family and my girlfriend is
pretty it's pretty simple and sounds
like you're very disciplined does that
come from the martial arts or did you
see that from one of your parents I
think that it does a lot come from the
martial arts I think it gives you a
certain work ethic but I think the
biggest thing that influences me it is
wanting it really badly I feel like I
really just just want it so bad that it
makes it a lot easier to be disciplined
when you really want something
you